pour ces départementale l'ump veut
frapper fort pierre bédier le président
sortant du conseil général souhaite
réaliser le grand chelem le parti
socialiste ne l'entend pas ainsi et
mobilise dès à présent ses troupes le ps
compte à ce jour neuf conseillers
généraux encartés socialistes ou
apparentés sur 39 on souhaite garder le
maximum de cantons que l'on détient on
en a pas énormément dans le département
c'est aussi la survie du débat
démocratique dans le département qui est
en jeu pour ce scrutin ce n'est plus un
candidat que les électeurs doivent élire
mais un binôme composé d'un homme et
d'une femme la prime est donnée au
sortant socialiste à commencer par le
maire de guyancourt et lui sur le canton
de montigny qui fera équipe avec la
première fédérale je veux porte un bilan
le travail de sept ans j'ai agi avec mes
collègues au sein du conseil général
pour que montigny pour guyancourt pour
saint quentin en yvelines j'arrive avec
une équipe est évidemment des
propositions pour l'avenir pour un
département de justice sociale et de
solidarité les acer qui en a bien besoin
on est dans des élections qui sont
extrêmement politique où l'enjeu c'est
aussi l'enjeu de faire valoir la
pluralité des voix au sein du conseil
départemental et donc il m'a semblé
important de faire partie de ce combat
politique là en tant que responsable
socialiste du département c'est pas
quand c'est simple qu'il faut y aller
c'est aussi quand c'est compliqué qu'il
faut y aller et jean philippe mallet lui
sera candidat sur le canton de saint cyr
l'école nous sommes pour des valeurs à
l'époque où là où la france
avec une chose grave profonde
nous voulons nous battre pour ces
valeurs qui ont été portées par le
peuple de france face à une équipe ump
usées le président du conseil général du
parti qui veut faire le grand chelem il
le dit partout il a écrit voilà c'est à
dire ils souhaitent avoir une assemblée
départementale monocolore uniquement
représentée par des élus ump il me
semble que ce n'est pas une bonne chose
pour la démocratie ce n'est pas une
bonne chose pas simplement pour la
gauche mais pour la démocratie et pour
nos concitoyens yvelinois donc voilà
nous sommes des militants de la
république c'est de porter des valeurs
de solidarité de fraternité et de
dynamisme économique avec une autre
vision de l'économie que celle qui est
actuellement portée qui est un peu
passéistes le canton de maurepas un
canton très élargie qui compte
dorénavant des communes de la vallée de
chevreuse qui votent à droite le
challenge sera donc difficile à relever
pour le sortant socialiste élu amour pas
toute élection est très difficile il
n'existe pas d'élections qui est qui est
très facile donc c'est à nous de
convaincre les habitants de ce canton on
part avec des avantages quand même
qu'ils sont assez assez forts de notre
de notre point de vue on a ticket
complémentaires on a certes des
concurrents entre guillemets mais ce
n'est pas notre priorité notre priorité
c'est de donner une réponse aux
territoires aux habitants en termes de
transport en terme de solidarité on fait
des réunions intersection là qui vont
débuter bientôt et ensuite nos feront du
porte-à-porte
va aller sur les marchés etc c'est
vraiment une
une campagne que l'on veut proche des
habitants sur le canton de plaisir jean
michel gourdon élu depuis deux mandats
ne se représente pas redonnez aussi du
dynamisme au département dynamisme que
qui est nécessaire pour pour le
territoire des yvelines qui aujourd'hui
a réellement besoin d'une autre
politique et notamment sur les
compétences premières qui sont les
siennes en matière sociale que ce soit
aussi bien sûr la petite enfance que sur
les seniors que sur la politique du
handicap mais aussi évidemment sur toute
la politique du logement et de
l'environnement
nicolas eu qui fera liste commune avec
frédéric evrard militants de plaisir
certains cantons n'ont pas encore
dévoilé leurs candidats c'est le cas
pour trappe qui compte dorénavant les
communes d'el en cours et de la verrière
jeanine marie conseillère générale
sortante divers gauche a souhaité se
représenter mais rien n'est encore
tranché pour la première fédérale on l'a
accompagné dans l'idée qu'il fallait en
tout cas le plus large rassemblement de
la gauche et le rassemblement de la
gauche c'est un combat donc on continue
de le mener parce que ça nous paraît
essentiel sur ce canton le maire de la
verrière le communiste alain jaj n'a pas
caché qu'il se lancerait aussi un canton
modifié et élargi à droite le maire ump
d'elancourt a déjà annoncé qu'il sera
candidat
la bataille s'annonce rude les derniers
arbitrages devraient être rendus
rapidement la clôture des dépôts des
listes est fixée au 16 février